ron you've been sweating in here all day
are you drinking any fluids yes plenty
no you need to drink water usually i
take it neat
but i will make an exception in the name
of health
last night i watched a movie with diane
and the girls
in which an orange fish is separated
from his father
the children were sniffling which i
believe to be due to the sad nature of
the film
i was wrong you need to take off those
layers rehydrate and go to the doctor
thank you for your concern i will be
fine
please turn the thermostat up to 90 and
leave me alone ron this isn't safe
i am a grown man i have had a cold
before
i need no help so if you don't
mind
that seems about right i'd like to
object again to being brought here
against my will okay i'm just gonna
double-check your form here
ron you redacted all the information i
answered some of them
for date of birth you wrote springtime
which is true
everything you write down is
confidential we need you to give real
answers
fine how many drinks of alcohol do you
consume a week
one that's it one drink one shelf
do you exercise yes lovemaking and
woodworking
do you have any history of mental
illness in your family i have an uncle
who does yoga
allergies cowardice and weak-willed men
and hazelnuts sexual history epic
and private okay i'm gonna go get your
doctor
he's a rude brash jerk you'll love him
before you begin a few ground rules i
need you to explain everything you do
before you do it so i can determine
whether i will allow you
oh
balsa wood you could at least use
mahogany
there's something occluding your ear
it's sawdust
just blue oh you've got strep throat
writing your prescription for penicillin
we'll have the rest of your test results
in about 20 minutes cholesterol
not interested good day
all patients were like that it's really
annoying when they ask questions
hey you look better i guess actual
medicine can be effective
who'da thunk please leave me alone not
until we go over your test results
and your blood work your blood pressure
looks fine i'm not sure how this is
possible but your cholesterol is 120
which is the lowest i've ever seen
what's cholesterol and the only problem
i see is that your potassium's low so
just eat a banana once in a while no
thank you
i live the way i live i eat the things i
eat
and i'll die the way i'll die that's
oddly beautiful
but also stupid you're not alone in the
world anymore ron
you're dating a woman who has two kids
so
every three days think about ivy and
zoey and diane
and eat a damn banana
hi ron hi ron
ladies ladies
um
you